eingegliedert zurück bei Bild live an
diesem Dienstag in der Woche in der
Deutschland die Kanzler auswechselt und
wir haben hier während wir dieser
Veranstaltung gelauscht und zugeschaut
haben mit Olaf Scholz Robert Habeck und
Christian Lindner Besuch bekommen bei
uns im Studio nicht nur von Bildpolitik
beschäftigen Schäfer sondern auch von
Wolfgang Kubicki herzlich Willkommen bei
uns das war entschuldigung aber ein
bisschen Schnarch Veranstaltung ehrlich
gesagt in Zeiten des Aufbruchs und so
weiter erwartet man ein bisschen was
anderes als vielleicht Olaf Scholz
schwarze Krawatte und doch ein relativ
müder Sound da ich habe mich während der
Veranstaltung bisschen gefragt wie kann
das sein dass die neue
aufbruchsregierung vor dem ersten
regierungstag müde aussieht als die
Kanzlerin vor ihrem letzten
regierungstag die habe ich ja die
Pressekonferenz nicht gesehen weil ich
ja auf dem Weg hierher war auch ein
bisschen mehr Drive reinzubringen die
Veranstaltung im Ernst ist es ja so wir
haben wirklich sehr anstrengende Wochen
hinter uns und man merkt heute ist ein
Abschluss gewesen ein erster Abschluss
mit der Unterzeichnung der
Koalitionsvereinbarungen und dann sagt
natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Weg das
muss man einfach menschlich
nachvollziehen das heißt aber sie Gemüte
tatsächlich an sie fangen an zu regieren
und sind schon müde nein die das
Kabinett wird ja morgen sozusagen erst
die Arbeit aufnehmen müssen die werden
heute Nacht mal richtig schön
ausschlafen und dann kann man sich
darauf verlassen nicht Deutschland wird
nicht so Schnarch nasig regiert werden
wie es in der Vergangenheit der Fall
gewesen ist das war jetzt heute die
zweite veranst
altung heute Morgen konnten wir sehen
wie der Koalitionsvertrag unterzeichnet
wurde auch da im futurium haben wir so
ein bisschen spaßeshalber gesagt hat
früher war irgendwie mehr Lametta auch
das wirkte so ein bisschen getragen wird
das ob sie gewirkt es sei ein großer
historischer Moment den kann man doch
eigentlich
Ergriffenheit
bei uns allen war ja schon vorhanden
nachdem klar aber dass die Partei mit
einer extrem großen Mehrheit zugestimmt
haben also ich kann mich an kein
Ergebnis erinnern bei dem mir was bei
den Freien Demokraten die deutlich über
90% lang bei der SPD fast 100 Prozent
bei den Grünen auch und dann weiß man es
hat jetzt funktioniert und der Rest ist
sozusagen nach dem symbolhafter Akt es
war deshalb nicht ganz zu ergreifen weil
der ganze Saal Feuerwehr mit
Journalisten nicht dass sie was gegen
Journalisten hätte aber
lag an der Crowd quasi wir waren etwas
gedrängt sozusagen durch die vielen
Journalisten die anwesend waren und
dabei sein wollten insofern warten wir
es doch einfach mal ab ich bin froh dass
wir jetzt den das Stadium erreicht haben
die alte Regierung abzulösen ein neues
zu installieren das wird morgen der Fall
sein
und dann geht es vorwärts tatsächlich
unsere kanzlerreporterin Angelika
Hellemann die heute morgen auch im
futurier mit dabei weil der hat
berichtet dass Toni Hofreiter einfach
nur hingegangen ist unterschrieben hat
und direkt danach den Saal verlassen hat
er ist immer noch frustriert darüber
dass er nicht Minister geworden ist
ja ich kann das nachvollziehen ich habe
ja eine Hauptbahnhof Gruppe mit ihm
gemeinsam nach dem mobilitätsteil
mitverhandelt es war eigentlich ein
Beteiligten klar dass er
Verkehrsminister wird deshalb haben wir
auch so verhandelt das müssen die Grünen
aber entscheiden es geht ja der
Grundsatz dass die Ministerien die den
jeweiligen Parteien zugeordnet werden
dann auch von ihnen selbst besetzt
werden was bei den Grünen sie abgespielt
hat weiß ich nicht aber noch einmal das
ist jetzt ein neuer Anfang dem wohnt ein
gewisser zauberende und ich glaube dass
daraus auch was Gutes werden kann setze
ihn Leid der Anton Hofreiter etwas das
muss man sagen wir haben ja mittlerweile
auch ein vernünftiges Verhältnis
zueinander gefunden ich weiß dass er
sehr viel von gutem Essen versteht dass
er auch gute Weine zu schätzen weiß und
dass er auch ein ein Mensch ist der
immer versucht einen Kompromiss zu
finden selbst wenn man aufeinander breit
also erst mir menschlich näher gekommen
und deshalb finde ich ein bisschen
traurig dass seine seine Vorstellung
sich nicht erfüllt haben haben sie da
ein Lieblings grün jetzt ich hatte immer
schon eine Lieblings ich habe mehrere
Lieblings grüne
interessanterweise alle weiblichen
Geschlecht das ist Steffi Lemke das ist
die kann ja kann ich nicht mehr Schaden
durch diese aus Frage das ist Claudia
Roth die seit über 50 Jahren kenne und
das ist Britta Hasselmann die neue
Fraktionsvorsitzende wird die wirklich
eine sehr gute kluge Parlamentarierin
ist jetzt hört man ja immer mehr dass es
Streitigkeiten gab sie haben jetzt einen
Streit schon bei den Grünen schon
angesprochen aber auch innerhalb der
Koalition lief natürlich nicht alles
immer nur Harmonie mäßig in den
vergangenen Wochen jetzt sagte Robert
Habeck der seien auch mal die Türen
geknallt in den Koalitionsgesprächen wer
hat die Tür geknallt sie nein aber ich
glaube dass das auch mehr bildlich
gemeint hat weil ich nicht erlebt habe
dass ich jemals Türen geknallt worden
sind aber selbstverständlich wenn man
aus unterschiedlichen Positionen kommt
und Kompromisse finden will kann es auch
mal deftig werden gerade mein Freund
Robert Habeck mit dem ich hier schon
alle wahrscheinlich ein bisschen genervt
aber es ist ja kolportiert worden es gab
einige auch in den verhandlungsgruppen
die anderen Buchstaben zu erklären wie
die Welt zu funktioniert und das ist
natürlich bei Menschen gestandenen
Alters dann schon sie ist schon wissen
schon also junge die den alten versucht
haben zu erklären oder Leute die also
der Grundsatz besteht nur daran wir
müssen nicht versuchen uns wechselseitig
zu überzeugen sondern wir müssen mal
gucken wie wir mit dem was in
unterschiedlichen Vorstellungen haben
zueinander kommen können und der Versuch
mir oder auch von uns der versucht
gelingen die andere davon zu überzeugen
dass das was wir glauben ist als ich
richtige ist das kann am Anfang nerven
aber das hat war relativ zügig vorbei
also das war nachher sehr professionell
sehr konzentriert in der Sache und
deshalb ist auch ein Koalitionsvertrag
zustande gekommen mit dem wir alle nicht
nur gut leben können sondern eine
wirklich eine gute Grundlage sein wird
für die nächsten vier Jahre und darauf
können alle Beteiligten sage ich mal
stolz sein wie funktioniert das
vielleicht können Sie das noch einmal
erklären Herr Kubicki weil sie hat schon
sehr lange in der Politik sind da
beschimpft man sich und bekämpft sich im
Parlament über vier Jahre vielleicht
sogar über acht Jahre die FDP und die
Grünen extrem hart gegeneinander das war
auch der erklärte Lieblingsgegner und
plötzlich sitzt man zusammen
Kabinettstisch und spielt so ein
bisschen Friede Freude Eierkuchen ist
das dann alles show was wieder sehen
oder ist das wirklich ernsthaft dass man
zusammengefunden hat und sagt okay also
plötzlich passen wir doch zusammen also
wenn das alles Show wäre dann würde
Politik ihre Funktion verfehlen denn wir
haben alle unsere Überzeugung für die
wir eintreten und kämpfen wir wissen
aber auch dass man pragmatisch an
Problemlösung herangehen muss es nützt
uns ja nichts wenn wir uns
gegenüberstehen und jetzt die nächsten
vier Jahre in der Ampelkoalition
bekriegen würden dann würde nichts
wirklich funktionieren schlechte
Beispiel hatten wir schon aus der großen
Koalition es macht Sinn den Versuch zu
unternehmen jetzt tatsächlich diesen
Fortschritts Pakt mit Leben zu erfüllen
und den Aufbruch wirklich zu wagen
selbst wenn das heute ein bisschen müder
ausgesehen hat ich bin mir sicher dass
alle Beteiligten dass er die
dokumentieren werden auch als Personen
dass sie an dem gemeinsamen Konzept
arbeiten und noch einmal lassen wir die
Leute erstmal anfangen geben wir ihn
tatsächlich ein bisschen Zeit sich auch
in den Ministerien zu organisieren
und ich bin sicher und das sage ich
jetzt nicht einfach so dahin ich habe
heute morgen mit Karl Lauterbach
beispielsweise noch mal gesprochen ich
bin sicher dass aus den Mahner Karl
Lauterbach auch ein Macher werden können
dass daran wird er gemessen werden und
diese Zeit sollten wir ein Beteiligten
geben über den Mann wollen wir nämlich
jetzt auch ganz in detailliert sprechen
sie sagen sie haben heute morgen mit ihm
telefoniert wir wollen einmal
reinschauen sie saßen ja mal mit Paul
ronsheimer zusammen und da war Karl
Lauterbach muss man sagen sie haben Sie
vielleicht nicht unbedingt geäußert dass
sie großer Fan sind wir schon einmal in
dieses Interview rein
wir gehen die Leute hier im in der
Stammkneipe auf Karl Lauterbach bei
ihnen nicht positiv was sagen sie so
also man würde im neuen so sagen eine
Spacken oder Dumpfbacke oder
hier sondern das weiß Karl Lauterbach
auch also auch die Maloche aus dem aus
Leverkusen und Bochum da wo er
kandidiert oh und da sind wir Ihnen mal
schnell ins Wort gefallen aber das
wichtige Wort das ist ja gefallen der
die liebevolle Bezeichnung für Karl
Lauterbach heute morgen haben sie mit
ihm telefoniert
gestern schon gratuliert dafür bedankt
wir haben uns heute morgen gesehen uns
ausgetauscht ich muss vielleicht mal
sagen weil das immer falsch komponiert
wird Spacken ist plattdeutsch und heißt
sowas wie jemand der einem auf die
Nerven geht das ist gar nicht böse
gemeint sondern der Leute die einem auf
die Nerven gehen und dazu gehörte Karl
Lauterbach bei mir jedenfalls und bei
meinem Umfeld als der ständige malermann
scherte den den Fernseher ein und der
erste der erklärt hat dass wir an der
Pandemie zugrunde gehen war Karl
Lauterbach das nervt ein bisschen und
jetzt wie gesagt das habe ich mir heute
morgen gesagt jetzt wird er daran
gemessen werden aber aus den vielen
Studien hier gelesen hat jetzt auch
praktische Politik folgt und wir die
Pandemie wirklich in den Griff bekommen
ohne dass wir den Leuten dauernd Angst
machen und noch einmal ich traue ihm das
zu aber es ist ambitioniert aber das ist
ja eigentlich schon tre Besitz der
Geschichte sie waren ja sozusagen die
Lieblingsgegner in der corona-krise wir
sind hier fast in keinem bildtalk da
ohne sie beiden auszukommen ausgekommen
weil sie eigentlich die maximalen
Gegenpole war und jetzt regieren sie
sozusagen gemeinsam machen gemeinsame
Sache in dieser Ampel Koalition können
sie das selber begreifen und vor allen
Dingen das wird es ihnen richtig schwer
machen
das weiß ich gar nicht weil wir beide
wechselseitig uns attestiert haben er
versteht mehr von Mediziner als ich und
ich verstehe mehr von Juristerei als er
und das hat ja sozusagen unseren unseren
Streit auch regelmäßig befeuert
er wird glaube ich in die Ministerium
sich anders verhalten müssen als
gegenwärtig in die Talkshows da war ja
der Liebling der Nation wir haben das
von Jens Spahn auch schon mal gesehen
der war im Dezember letzten Jahres der
Liebling der Nation der Mann der am
beliebtesten war in Deutschland sich
überlegt hat aber nicht vielleicht
kannst Du Kandidat der Union wird und
dann kam ein dramatischer Absturz das
wünsche ich Karl Lauterbach nicht im
Gegenteil ich wünsche uns insgesamt dass
wir möglichst schnell aus dieser
pandemie-situation herauskommen aus dem
Lockdown das nervt ja mittlerweile alle
Beteiligten und deshalb werden wir alles
dafür tun ihnen auch zum erfolgreichen
Gesundheitsminister zu machen weil es
für uns gut ist und wenn das eben Karl
Lauterbach ist von mir aus aber wenn sie
sagen Karl Lauterbach versteht mehr von
Medizin und sie mehr von Juristerei in
den letzten Wochen ging es immer noch
hoch Herz zwischen ihnen beiden das
heißt dieser Streit ist jetzt beigelegt
Wolfgang Kubicki wird sich an Karl
Lauterbach nicht mehr abarbeiten nein
nein also der innerliche Streit der
bleibt also im Schreiben positiven Sinne
wir werden selbstverständlich auch
unsere wechselseitig unterschiedlichen
Positionen nach wie vor markieren aber
nicht mit dem Hinblick darauf den
anderen jetzt aus dem Feld zu räumen
sondern daraus was gemeinsam produktives
zu machen das ist ja der Sinn dieser
Koalition wir kommen aus völlig
unterschiedlichen Vorstellungswelten und
versuchen daraus was gemeinsam
vernünftiges zu machen daran werden wir
gemessen werden niemand wird erfolgreich
sein auf Kosten der anderen wir werden
nur gemeinsam erfolgreich
oder Christian Lindner ich habe beide
ein sehr ambitioniertes Amt TK
Lauterbach wie gesagt weil daran
gemessen wird ob aus dem Mana kann auch
dabei jetzt der Macher wird der das
tatsächlich umsetzt was er immer wieder
gefordert hat ich fand die Bedienung
dass das Gesundheitssystem jetzt eine
stabilisierten aufgebaut wird schon sehr
ambitioniert weil es ja auch immer mit
Kosten verbunden ist und Christian
Lindner aber der dokumentieren muss
definitiv dass die Überlegung der Freien
Demokraten wir können das alles wuppen
ohne dass wir Steuererhöhungen machen
müssen und ohne dass die Schuldenbremse
angefasst werden muss dass das
Wirklichkeit werden kann daran werden
wir als Freie Demokraten gemessen also
für uns ist die Funktion von Christian
Lindner bedeutender für die Republik die
nächsten Wochen und Monate die Funktion
von Karl Lauterbach richtig auch als
würde auch ihnen gerade in der
Pressekonferenz wieder angesprochen ein
Thema das ganz Deutschland bewegt die
Impfpflicht für viele fühlen dass es so
ist das Tage Wochen monatelang fast
jahrelang versprochen wurde das kommt
nicht bei uns das wird nicht kommen und
gerade die FDP hat sich da ganz klar
positioniert wir haben es eben gerade
auch wieder gehört von Christian Lindner
der sagte die Einführung einer
Impfpflicht ist kein Vorhaben der
Ampelkoalition gleichzeitig musste er
aber auch ein bisschen vorsichtiger in
den Formulierungen werden da alle
unsicher in die Zukunft blicken und es
jetzt eben doch diskutiert wird hier
stehen sie das ja diskutiert wird ist in
Ordnung über Maßnahmen diskutieren
müssen ist in Ordnung in meiner Partei
gibt es eine sehr intensive Diskussion
über die Vor- und Nachteile einer
Impfpflicht ich selbst das wissen alle
beteiligt ich bin gegen eine generelle
Impfpflicht aus muss das ja nicht
erklären das entspricht nicht meinem
Menschenbild was ich habe und vor allen
Dingen könnte ich mich mit dem Gedanken
anfreunden wenn die impfpflichtungs aus
der Pandemie herausführen würde ich
halte das für eine freche Behauptung
denn wir wissen mittlerweile das auch
die Menschen die gebootet sind wieder
infiziert werden können und andere
infizieren können und dass die uns der
Prozess längerer Zeit begleiten wird ich
bin für mehr Aufklärung für mehr
Kampagnen ich glaube dass viele Menschen
die sich momentan nicht impfen lassen
diesen Schritt dann wagen wenn wir ein
Tod Impfstoff haben der ist ziemlich
zugelassen werden wird ich kriege jeden
Tag wirklich hunderte von Mails von mir
geschrieben wird Überblick ich lass mich
sofort impfen so wie dieser Impfstoff am
Markt ist also in einer freien
Gesellschaft wie unsere bin ich mehr für
Überzeugung als für diese für diese
nächste Herangehensweise aber ich kann
Menschen auch verstehen die glauben
nicht wenn wir alle durchgeimpft sind
dann haben wir das Problem im Griff und
dann machen wir das wie gesagt mit
meinem Rechtsverständnis ist mit meinen
Menschenbild schon gar nicht wir
diskutieren momentan eine sektorale
Impfpflicht oder vielleicht auch eine
altersbegrenzte impfpflichte Ethikrat
wird das wahrscheinlich vorschlagen
Menschen ab 60 sollten sich alle impfen
lassen Pflicht in der Pflicht darüber
kann man wirklich nachdenken noch einmal
ich bin da insgesamt sehr skeptisch wenn
man jetzt gegen die Impfpflicht ist und
bleibt findet man dann in der FDP sein
natürliches zuhause oder hat man in
Deutschland extreme Position damit nein
in der Freien Demokraten finden Sie auf
jeden Fall zu Hause weil wir das sehr
offen und ohne Diskriminierung ist
jeweils anderen
diskutieren es gibt ja für beides gute
Argumente und die Überlegung nicht man
ist ein besserer Mensch wenn man sich
für die ein oder andere Seite
entscheidet die ist in der freien
demokratischen Partei nicht sehr weit
verbreitet wir diskutiert die
diskutieren das rational es gibt nicht
bessere Menschen in der ein oder anderen
Richtung
ich finde es schön wenn Leute sagen sie
haben dazu gelernt und ich habe auch
dazu gelernt aber es hat meine Position
nicht verändert und insofern finde ich
dass wir in Deutschland wenn wir viel
offener miteinander reden würden und die
jeweils moralischen Senkel zu stellen
viel weiter kommen würden als wir es
gegenwärtig tun waren wir doch mal eine
Prognose Herr Kubicki wenn es zur
Abstimmung kommt über die allgemeine
Impfpflicht Christian Lindner hat gerade
auch noch mal gesagt es wird
gruppenanträge geben das heißt es wird
dann ja auch fraktionsübergabe oder
fraktionsfrei abgestimmt werden ihre
Einschätzung einfach nur eine Prognose
kurz vor Weihnachten 2021 wird der
Bundestag mehrheitlich für eine
allgemeine impfpflichtstimmung oder
hören Sie das von vielen Kollegen die
sagen nein wir sind doch dagegen das
wird keine Mehrheit geben in der
Bundestag wird mit Mehrheit dafür
stimmen weil ich weiß dass aus den
Reihen der CDC ist für
Bundestagsfraktion sehr viele
Kolleginnen Kollegen dafür stimmen
würden bei den Sozialdemokraten und
Grünen ist auch so bei den Freien
Demokraten würde ich das ungefähr
schätzen zwischen 30 40 Prozent die
gegen eine allgemeine Impfpflicht sind
der Rest würde dafür stimmen wie gesagt
auch mit guten Argumenten es wäre eine
beachtliche Minderheit im Deutschen
Bundestag außerhalb der AFD mit den
wollen wir jetzt gar nicht reden die
trotzdem eine allgemein Impfpflicht
nicht zustimmen würden aber es wird eine
mehr den Deutschen Bundestag okay sie
gehen davon aus es wird eine Mehrheit
geben ja ich kann das be ich kann es
nicht ändern jetzt ist morgen kein ganz
unerheblicher Tag Scholz kommt und
Merkel geht nach so vielen Jahren
wirklich in historischer Tag mit
Zeitenwende Machtwechsel hier in
Deutschland sie haben jetzt noch so
zweieinhalb Minuten Zeit hier bei uns um
noch mal alles über Angela Merkel zu
erzählen über ihre persönliche
politische Beziehung ihr Verhältnis was
Deutschland noch nicht wusste also über
Angela Merkel jetzt zweieinhalb Minuten
zu reden ist er ist sehr vermessen aber
ich kann nur noch mal wiederholen dass
ich Angela Merkel in den verhandlungs
2017 kennengelernt habe als eine sehr
charmante kluge Gastgeberin mit einem
unglaublich britischen Humor den
verstehen nicht alle sofort für einen
norddeutschen ist das relativ einfach
aber sie ist eine wirklich
beeindruckende Persönlichkeit
beeindruckende Frau und sie hat nicht
alles falsch gemacht in den letzten 16
Jahren das muss man wirklich sagen ich
glaube wir hätten ohne sie und per Stein
wird die Finanzkrise 2009 nicht so
anständig überlebt aber was wird dann
jetzt Olaf Scholz anders machen als
Angela Merkel
vom Auftritt her wahrscheinlich wenig
das haben sie ja schon gesehen die sind
ja beide sehr zurückhaltend in ihrem
Auftritt aber er wird andere Akzente
setzen selbstverständlich als
Sozialdemokraten mit ganzem Herzen und
das wird sich schon als Abzeichen der
Regierungspolitik
so blicken wir dann in die Zukunft was
glauben Sie wo wird es auch mal
Reibungspunkte geben auch wenn ich gerne
optimistisch abschließen möchte aber ich
möchte mich doch auch darauf vorbereiten
wo sind Punkte wo sie jetzt schon sagen
oh da müssen wir jetzt in Zukunft das
wird uns beschäftigen und da sind wir
uns vielleicht nicht immer weg also ich
hoffe dass es jeden Tag Reibungspunkte
geben wird weil das können wir werden
wenn ich erzeugen selbstverständlich
wird auch im regierungshandel immer
wieder die Frage auftauchen dient das
der Weiterentwicklung unseres Landes ja
oder nein es wird Diskussionen geben
weil der Mobilität bei der Frage welche
Autobahn bauen wir noch ja oder nein ich
bin ja Verfechter der A20 und die wird
auch gebaut werden kann ich schon sagen
aber trotzdem es wird
immer noch jeden Tag die Frage im Raum
stehen ist das jetzt prioritär was wir
machen oder können wir es zurückstellen
denn wie gesagt auch unsere Finanzen
wachsen nicht unbedingt in den Himmel
irgendwer muss es bezahlen auch das
werden wir beide sein weil wir alle sein
das wird die deutsche Bevölkerung sein
jetzt bezahlt die Wirtschaft und die
Menschen die hart arbeiten